okay well for people who are watching on
the livestream um this is a internal
language development meeting about
Wolfram language we hold many of these
and this is a collection of different
topics that we have today let's start
going through them so first one is about
coefficient rules and Laurent
polynomials
okay so here the point is that some of
our functions to get coefficients are
able to deal with negative powers but
others do not and Eric suggested that we
extend coefficient rules to handle also
negative powers
portes coefficient rules too right now
with negative powers just ignores them
basically gets totally confused because
you see there it's saying at zero order
or Silla power it it assigns everything
as being independent of X that seems
kind of stupid so coefficient list
itself if I just do coefficient list so
if I have that polynomial where with a
coefficient list coefficient list is one
function this is discussed further than
that cannot handle negative because it's
it's because of the polynomial yes
so because the output is then um the
coefficients at order at power zero one
two three
this cannot be extended to a negatives
because then the list is not properly
positioned okay so coefficient
coefficient list
in a race and think there is no hope of
of extending them but coefficient goals
because it has on the left-hand side of
the rules they say power then it could
be extended yeah I understand I mean we
could do something like what array does
oh I see here we have the dimensions
truncating or padding with zeros gives
an array of those dimensions right yes
so similar to array itself right which
has an origin point right if I if I look
at array well let's say this is
coefficient arrays right it's there's
the other case here yes
okay so one could certainly imagine just
like with array itself than there's an
origin and index origin that you can
specify right right good good point yeah
we could do that I don't know whether
it's particularly useful I mean it might
be useful because right now these are 0
origin arrays right because if I do a
coefficient array of something that has
okay I mean good yes this first array
that you see in the example of
coefficients are raised would be the
derivative of customs
with with that additional argument we
could extend this I mean I don't know
how much we care but it's where does it
say that's not a polynomial that seems
like it should be a polynomial but if
you put it inside to expand I don't need
one to tie it's not supposed to be
necessary right it's supposed to do the
computation whether or not it has yeah
what the heck is this yes so this is
this is the notation so cause efficient
erase is more for the multi dimensional
multivariable case yeah
in this case it's I mean it's system
considering that that it's an array so
it's a race of dimension one dimension
all right look I think I mean my point
of view here this is hardly the most
critical thing if we can get coefficient
rules to work fine I don't see any
reason not to make it work um that so
what it's doing here is it's with
respect to the list of variables here so
each one of these will be it's a sparse
thing where each one of those will just
be the the the exponent list
exactly for a given monomial seems fine
to me I mean the rules case seems fine
the coefficient list case seems like
yeah I mean that's sort of interesting
this this padding or whatever I think
this isn't the tale of what anybody
might care about but I you know as I say
because this is starting with powers
zero hmm oh I see so that goes so the
first element is the is so it's the
opposite way around from digits so to
speak so coefficient Lisa the opposite
waiting around from integer digits yeah
do we say that by the way in here oh
yeah okay yep
good okay seems reasonable to me now in
terms of coefficient of rise I just
think don't think we should worry about
that right now yeah I think the
important thing is to have one function
that is able to do it directly okay
sounds good that's another small thing a
suggestion of having our timing
functions producing quantities yes that
is something that is requested
periodically and and some of our like
ping time now returns a quantity right
so I mean right
so the question
deserves a new function or whether we
can add the second argument in timing
and absolute timing to handle this for
example yes well what do we think I mean
in you know I'm not the biggest fan of
the way that timing works I mean in
other words um I don't do this so that I
get a reasonable time here okay I mean
the fact that this is coming back as you
know first element second element thing
is hardly my absolute favorite but I
don't see a lot of choice I mean if I
said here repeated timing is repeated
timing use and quantities or not know
it's following them okay and there's no
second argument to timing right not now
but to repeated timing
perhaps because we have discussed in the
past the possibility of specifying some
statistical arguments there at least
three seconds so I've already got that
hump
okay so the issue is your question is is
there a way to
yeah I mean it's a shame we can't do
this but but um okay so what are the
possibilities one possibility is to
simply change these to return quantities
my guess is that's a bad idea yes yes we
could break too many things but I mean a
second argument I think could be safe
yeah well that will work his repeated
timing can't have a second argument it's
already gotten a timeout argument well
perhaps by the way I mean this time
constraint take um it takes quantities
all the timing functions allow
consumption of quantities but we've
tried not to generate them from a lot of
the functions that have been around for
a long time just because there's so much
potential for problem and legacy code
that's checking your absolute timing is
less than four is going to be
problematic if it returns a quantity of
seconds all right so what we've got
right now is a cluster of three timing
functions timing absolute timing and
repeated timing so one possibility would
be to have a new function that perhaps
wraps together all of those
I don't know I mean that the this
timing and absolute timing is quite
useful and widely used yeah what would
we want you know in a perfect world what
would the timing functions return would
it be these pairs or would it be
something different I mean or would it
be that instead we want some super
function that is you know something like
evaluation report of exper returning a
something that says you know CPU timing
absolute timing memory used result that
seems like it might be a useful thing um
so that then I mean that that's the
question is whether that would be a now
how does that relate to evaluation data
which is used in how does that relate to
this oh well maybe we've already got
this answer
okay that's kind of annoying that would
be um um um let's see
evaluation data so why why does one not
use evaluation data and by the way one
earth is evaluation data coming back
with timings not with quantities I don't
know okay that's interesting
what does output log do you think I must
I use this function yet right well this
function is used in web calls right it's
used in the API mechanism for that this
is what populates the JSON response data
for an API call am i making sense
hmm personally I think we should
consider again we have to look at how
that flows through response for maybe
you can talk to the folks who deal with
this okay and see whether we can change
these to have quantities right now
whether that would be okay and if so or
whether that will just produce a
disaster and if we can just concentrate
on oh this is very weird that that's a
Quran greater than thing but that we can
concentrate on something like this
evaluation data or evaluation report um
I mean if it's a report like that one
could even imagine a dataset format of
the thing right other words if you care
more about the details of what happened
then you care about the actual results
itself um this might be a nice form the
other possibility would be I mean the
question is how does one use this does
one just want the timing information
right I think I've knowed was going in
declaration because he was interested
for example in specifying the unit he
wanted well I think specifying a unit in
the arguments of evaluation data would
be an overkill
so from evaluation data we would expect
that the function chooses are a correct
unit yeah I understand that I mean but
but the issue here is look the basic
problem is that timing doesn't just give
you the timing it gives you this pair
which is the time and the results I'm
okay with that yeah it's it's often
useful I mean sometimes you just want
the timing and you end up saying first
of timing right yes hum
alright look I think the thing we need
to do is understand how this response
forms stuff works and consider this
evaluation data possibility I think that
the okay so what are the branches here
one branch is we got these three
functions timing absolute timing
repeated timing right
second argument possibility is not great
well I mean it is doable because
repeated timing if it took a string a
second argument that can disambiguate
relative to having an actual quantity in
the second argument my making sense it
won't work if you do control equals
milliseconds because what will then
happen is that will turn into one
millisecond they think I certainly yes
so okay so the possibilities are a unit
specification in the second argument
with the possibility of timing blah blah
blah comma automatic for example meaning
use the sensible unit not crazy um and
the way that this would look otherwise
is timing blah blah blah comma seconds
would give the timing in seconds now
would it give it as a quantity with
seconds yes I think so yes well okay so
look that is a simple thing I think
these other thing is to change
evaluation data to return things with
quantities here I think it would also be
useful to do a survey of all functions
that take a neck you said that you've
dealt with all functions that take times
as inputs and made them support
quantities right yeah we did a scan
through we ended up missing one or two
but we've patched those up since then so
they should all do you know which
functions return times though there are
not an enormous number of them so there
are various import formats that will pre
generate quantities or various data
functions that will spit out quantities
I don't know if many you know these are
basically the evaluation timing
functions and they currently don't
return quantities okay well so wait a
second which don't return these ones
here don't these ones don't return
quantities again
consideration being we want to make sure
everything consumed stuff before we
start producing it in a lot of places
all right so my tendency is to say this
is a reasonable approach this is like an
argument to purchase a reasonable
approach I think we should consider re
redoing evaluation data to change that
to be quantities but I would like you to
go understand how response form uses it
makes sense okay yeah okay all right
onward okay so this is a suggestion from
myself so I use a lot this combination
which is I want to find all about from
language symbols which have some given
option or attribute and then I always
have to write this combination of a
function so I would really like to have
something simpler okay so you're
suggesting some something that is in
Wolfram language data that is relevant
to the class what's that I there's
something new there or or a given new
function so edit or suggestion for
example always saying that for some data
functions we have a lookup function so I
wonder what they're over from language
lookup well we have that without like
Wikipedia data no do we we don't really
we have it for like formula data with
formula lookup but that's generally
looking at like standard names for
things
something that
simple as the options goes to your
projection and gives me the symbols with
your projection
I think this would help in in right but
I mean isn't that consistent with okay
so there's an entity specified there so
if I say well from language data I mean
if I was simply saying option
oh I see
yeah I mean something like this option
arrow you know nearest I don't know what
a feature extractor is that the kind of
thing you want yes for example I mean
what what you're saying is that if I say
Wolfen language data of quotes options
what that's right now going to do is
give the entity associated with options
right exactly so the issue here is can
you give a list of entities that have
certain features I mean you know I could
imagine something where you would say
show me the see also of such and such a
thing now you can presumably get the see
also is by saying here how does this
work does this say seal so how do I get
to see also it's possible to to do it
I done know related symbol soon
you
I said that takes so long okay
so Wolfram language data is super
powerful it has lots of information it's
it's just that sometimes it's a bit
difficult to get something simple okay
so look
one possibility is to have another
property name and is anybody who's
worked on off language data here
unfortunately no I thought very but he
couldn't have done okay I mean it's kind
of like
yeah okay I mean it seems okay so there
two possibilities one is some kind of
notation that would have Wolfram
language data return a list here and I
think it's more natural to have given
the name of an option like if we ask for
Wolfram language data all feature
extractor for example um what you said
there which is functions that have that
option
I see okay fine but then so then what
would we call that that property um
option steamboats soon singles with
option
let's see what some of these are
common option values okay so yeah I mean
symbols with option I guess
cymbals having option it's a little bit
funky isn't it because yeah it's a
property that only works for some well
no it's just it'll just give a null list
um option would we need to say we also
need the same thing for attributes right
um so here we have things like um okay
by the way we really do need to know why
that was slow and I have a bad feeling
it had something to do with the yellow
box formatting business Nick I think
that's yours yeah I'm taking a look at
it okay and by the way Nick on the on
the business about synchronous like
synchronous cash yes and crispy fetching
are you on that or do we need to talk
about that more I'm looking at it we had
had some conversation at some point back
where we were looking at you know how
that relates to the the general sort of
notion of the the new compiler in terms
of recognizing inefficient code paths
and how they would be addressed in the
language in general but I think that's a
that's a bigger story I mean that the
story right now is you're just doing
something which needs a lot of entities
you've already got five of them you've
got 50 to go we need to actually do the
prefetch at that point right in the in
the case you give is a good example
where it takes two minutes to do one at
a time and it takes two seconds to grab
all of them so right if we recognize
that case readily there you know there's
going to be some heuristics in terms of
fine-tuning the behavior but
structurally you can do that you can
just pause the computation do a
synchronous prefetch and then going yes
yes we can do that we just need to sort
out the exact parameters that trigger
that which is the same thing we did with
prefetching there's a little bit of
fiddling we'll okay and the yellow box
formatting stuff is that
have you straightened that out now or
not yeah we had a discussion with Jeremy
Tony and Lou about it and their you know
the the cases that bob was looking at
where they were really bad timings were
kind of a worst case scenario where
basically the entire cache had been
blown away and even though the client
had the information need to type said it
was making some metadata calls and we're
factoring those out now okay is this
affected updateable yeah it is all
peclet updatable say okay if we get it
end up and tested well we can roll it
out it okay terrific
okay let's go back to this name um as
it's kind of awkward then it'd be nice
to say
something like option uses that's kind
of weird as well
you
option using symbol that's terrible
well I would say look I think symbols
with option anybody got a better
suggestion
option symbols would be kind of proper
but difficult to understand but I guess
once you know it I think option symbols
is incomprehensible largely and
comprehensible I mean you have to know
it's as an option okay what is the full
statement here the full statement is
symbols that
well symbols that use this symbol as an
option
include adoption
you
you
maybe along the lines of our contains
function contains option but what about
using as option okay is symbols using as
option comprehensible I think yes
absolute silence and I'm trying to think
whether it's possible to read in which
direction it goes
I understand
you
on the livestream Michael Hale is
pointing out that the yellow box
particularly that he's noticed the
yellow boxes are particularly slower
it's a long list and it's producing a
shortened form of output to display
that's actually an interesting case Nick
does it go and fetch those things before
it does the shortening yeah it does
because of the way that shorten happens
to work we have yeah we've put in
optimization for long lists where
instead of fetching them one by one we
we fetch them efficiently wouldn't it be
nice to not fetch them if it's short man
yeah I've talked with it with ETA about
that a little bit and there there's some
modernization people would like to do in
terms of the way that short works but it
it is in a field that I'm not at all
familiar with and it's a more general
problem than just with with entities
because there are problems for example
with any template boxes the shortened
code doesn't actually know how big they
are so sometimes you can get a shortened
list that it actually is way longer than
it should be because it treats each
boxes being only a single character even
though they could be you know 40
characters long I see the toe so that
does seem like something that's
important to look at I mean the issue is
can we make the the formatting stuff be
lazy for example in the case of a you
know I don't know exactly at what point
in the you know in the code how does
that code path work with respect to
whether the front end is requesting
stuff or whether we're pushing stuff out
anyway I don't know but that Thanks
Michael Hale for the the comment about
that that's a I that's that's a good
thing to be paying attention to all
right back to this um
okay what something like used us option
something like an sounds like an active
like a boolean but okay sander on the
live stream is saying general criteria
for filtering will be like nice like in
component measurements I'm not quite
sure what else right I mean it would be
a pure function that can tell one get
those things which have attributes you
know hold and hold first and so on but
you know by the time you're doing that
you might as well be just going ahead
and just doing it yourself so to speak
Oracle using the entity implicit and in
the language which is what I had above
so this is powerful it is that it's a
bit longer to write when you want
something single in this case yeah yeah
fair enough okay so just a minute let's
let's go down here um gosh what
here so symbols that use this symbol as
an option
I think symbols using as an option poof
symbols using as an option it's the
I can do right now if we have no further
to jet other suggestions I suggest we
implement this this this [ __ ] that
name symbols using using as attribute
it's a little more obscure for
attributes
I think it's comprehensible it's not
great um alright let's move on I think
that'll okay should level get an l-value
my gosh okay so we get it
yep yes so this is one of these cases in
which I hmm I try to propose an
alternative so that's why it's a bit
longer so I don't think we should do
anything special for all four level
mainly because level returns have flat
list of things and you are not sure
where they were and I think we can do
something more general with a function
called reset part which would follow
replaced part that would allow
specifying like replaced part itself
does where do you want to change things
and perhaps you can introduce if this is
really a symbolic version of the list of
positions at a given level I understand
so the issue is replaced part is
perfectly happy to have okay so let's
take a look at this so we've got
replaced part of an expression let's
let's have a random expression here I
don't know you've got you got a little
expression here um so you're saying
replace part in this two color one arrow
why why why I don't know where was two
comma one didn't it have a 2 comma 1 or
1 comma 2
okay fine all right so now the question
is and we can also say 1 comma blank
arrow yyy right the list of positions
right right so the question is what
you're saying is a level a level is
those parts which have a certain number
of I mean why isn't a level I don't
understand why why saying level 2 why
replace on level 2 isn't just that well
because precisely here are carly's
talking about a negative level which is
something that counts from yeah this is
very obscure okay so the question is so
what is a negative level a negative
level is something whose part
specification has a okay so a positive
level is something while you're walking
down the tree and every elements of the
index list takes you on the specified
branch as you go down the tree
there isn't a negative part
specification there is only a negative
level as in request to the bottom of the
tree and start going up from the bottom
right yep the most interesting case
being parts that are at the you know at
the bottom of the tree so to speak
leaves of the tree I have to say I think
you know our new tree manipulation stuff
seems like the best place to think about
these kinds of things
you know if you're really that keen to
replace the leaves of a thing I think
this is really a weird case but if
you're really that keen to replace the
leaves turn the expression into a tree
and then go to town and do whatever tree
manipulation you want and then turn it
back to an expression that's what I
think
okay by the way when are we next looking
at the the trees stuff when when shibir
is suspect okay he has taken some time
recently
okay I mean what's the time scale like a
week or so yes I think when doing this
at most okay alright so so I think
there's nothing more to do on this okay
except I think we we should be thinking
about examples of the tree stuff that
term you know involve that kind of
global expression replacement
all right position patterns yes so this
is a continuation of our discussion last
week in which you suggested to explore
the possibility of having patterns
specifying lists or collections of
positions let me do interface part okay
so in this case for example we can use
that pattern I I prank you to replace
the diagonal elements some of the
elements in a matrix so the question is
whether we can extend something like
that to say extract and why wouldn't we
do that well I was thinking that they
the nice thing of replaced part is that
it has the patterns inside the rule so
from the scoping point of view it looks
nice yeah but if we put it and in fact I
have that come and they added replaced
part until version six or so had this
alternative notation in which there were
arguments rather than rules yep and that
didn't accept patterns and I think
precisely because of that reason they
could have put two different eyes in
different arguments because there
wouldn't be properly scoped sure but
this is the isn't that's the situation
with cases without a right hand side
right I mean the extract thing is like a
cases well the point is that
in cases we have a patent for the thing
we are extracting not for the position
we are acting at no I understand that
this is this is a new use of patterns
for the position now
now clearly doesn't what happens if you
patronize the keys in an association in
other words let's imagine we're doing
this because this should work also for
associations shouldn't it okay no
absolutely we have a potential syntax
extension using patterns for I mean that
there's two points here first of all in
some complicated cases like for example
XML trees well you've always had a hard
time actually having a good notation for
kind of the index path down an XML tree
now that may change with the tree stuff
right right hmm but in this case okay so
I don't quite understand the objection
here so what's the problem here so if I
say the objection is basically that I
don't think we'd have a precedent for
this so this would be an extension to
something that we don't do yet so I've
got to make sure that okay so you're
saying that we're introducing variables
here that
ah for example those names I blank and I
blank um the name I I mean we could make
this a scope and construct with respect
to that second argument I think that's
problematic and and make it
because normally that second argument
will be a literal right so there's the
only case of non literals that we're
dealing with that I mean do you agree
that this case if I say that table okay
so let's look at that table um
the diagonal of that table mm-hmm okay
that if I said extract I mean could we
even imagine this working well could we
imagine no is this crazy I yeah I think
that part language is a lot more strict
the deposition language can be extended
but the part language I know there's a
penis in Canada why why what's the
I'm I'm not sure how to explain it it's
like the the patterns we can't we can
think that the patterns in the position
language represent a list of the must
patterns in part is it because it works
by by by sex by slices so part doesn't
try to connect one level to the other
level okay so so yes difficult to
replace I I buy something unique that
represents that yeah I understand
because because part I mean part of the
point you're making there is that this
is equivalent to I blank I blank and
that then it's gonna get really crazy
because how does it know that those
different levels in the sense of that
sub value structure that those two eyes
are the same thing
I think what I'm saying is that right
now with our part language we cannot
extract as I ever met no matter what we
do and so converting these into
something that currently works could be
difficult yeah I understand it's also an
l-value
which makes it even more complicated
alright so but let's look at extract for
a minute okay so clearly replaced part
knows where those parts are you know
where those patterned parts are yeah
right so could we I see but it is
replacing them back into the structure
of the thing so I mean in principle
somewhat bizarrely
we could you know we could write this as
a piece of code that says that and we
could throw a bunch of things out that
are the extracted things and catch them
and we get this result right
interestingly a replaced part once we
have identified in identified a I we we
can replace by something that depends on
I but it's not so easy to replace by
something that depends on the actual
thing that was there we'll have a
notation for that yeah I know that's map
at basically I mean that raises the
question whether map at should take
patterns which seems to me quite
sensible
quite interesting with respective thing
we were just discussing about level
specs
Matt took patterns one could imagine
something where the pattern where the
index patterns so to speak said well
what would we what will be level minus
one in index patterns well that's a
that's kind of an exotic thing it's it's
a longest of a it's some kind of longest
of blanks or something what is this what
you want to do I'm trying to make the
index pattern for level minus one for
the leaves of the tree by the way if we
talk about doing this in extract we
absolutely should talk about doing this
in map at right are there any other
places where we should be looking at
this yes so the collections are is
extracting apart insert delete or a flat
not
as well yeah what does insert look like
for this purpose
well it is something that is inserted so
for example I mean this would be not be
a crazy thing if I said insert in my
list here something like um a blank
question mark even Q comma you know X or
something that will be pretty cool that
will be a riffle that's nice
all right so okay so the objection is
the scoping of named pattern variables
is that right I mean other than that is
there any known objection no I think
this can't work
is it simply something would have been
never done before and I just want to
make sure that because it's going to
take some some work to do to don't you
know I understand that is look I think I
mean map hat will be a nice one to have
I would think I think because this
basically is it right that that would
say map at level two is that right yeah
I think so that would say that would
mean map at level two that's equivalent
to map F X bar actually at level two yes
it's nice it's very nice I think this is
a nice thing let's try and make it work
and in terms of the scoping of these
variables I I think these things can be
scoping constructs with respect to that
argument I don't see a huge problem with
that I mean your concern is that that
variable is sort of localized to the
index matching and does not connect to
any kind of you know variable in the in
the actual expression right yes yes
we'll have there something that we
typically use patterns on well if the
thing is a rule like interface part then
it's natural to put buttons that was my
only objective objection so that's why
perhaps if we force the use of a rule in
extract then we are more motivated to
have buttons but then I don't know what
to put on the right-hand side sorry I'm
sorry I missed something well what yes I
was thinking if we if to use patterns we
we force having a rule in the second
argument of extract so that we kind of
know we are going to put their patterns
then I don't know what to put on the
rice concept no I don't think there's
anything to put on the right hand side
it doesn't have a right hand side just
like in I mean okay so the question is
look I mean cases is a perfectly good
example of where it doesn't need to have
something on the right hand side of the
pattern but I understand that I
understand that so you're asking is
there any meaning to putting something
on the right hand side of a rule there
with a pattern right I don't see it
because you're not returning I mean look
there's something utterly exotic you can
put there which is some kind of function
to apply to that part but I think that's
just exotic and pointless right it would
be like this extraction version
profitably spot yes or alternatively it
will be like a map at well my part would
leave all the rest while extract would
only extract and apply to those yeah
okay I mean look clearly extract having
a third argument of hold which it does
you know you could imagine doing
something exotic with that but I think
let's not worry about it I don't see I
don't see a value to that what but I
think this is really nice having pattern
I mean this is something we've sort of
been circling around for probably 15
years of having you know full support
for pattern pattern part you know
pattern indices that's good all right
let us go on since we have some time
left here a little bit of time um I was
going to go through
some of the low-hanging items does
anybody so the array association thing
do we need to talk about that here no I
don't think so that's on my plate okay I
will try to have it on the agenda next
week okay great um who is dealing with
the the chat functionality function
support 3d Angie okay they're going to
meet at some point soon okay all right
fine okay let's see and I guess on this
list external value is something that
Garret is dealing with is that right yes
it's it's part of CSC good and the thing
happen with find character encoding he
is working on it and I've been checking
converging I remember she said she said
it is a little complicated then she
thought it is so maybe I will ask her to
use machine learning to be able to find
out for a given piece of text to be able
to guess what character encoding it's
using not the Kevin piece of text rather
a given bytearray
figure out what is it and by the way
this year is she aware of the fact that
we're going to multi to non plane zero
Unicode right because that's another
possible if you've fed a piece of a byte
array one thing it could represent is a
bunch of random emoji in things am I
making sense okay um let's see what
turn to the column map functions and so
on are those being worked on
yes that's me yes let's discuss it in
the next agenda as well
okay flattened again I need the tie for
that he had some some valid concerns and
I don't remember but we need to have him
in in one of these meetings or perhaps
discussing us in C with him okay did we
ever
let's see things like whenever happened
to integer fractional part oh I think
it's just that we thought we have more
important things to do we can work on
that as well at some point we were very
interested in these pair functions yes
and that's why we introduced some of
these but you know we should switch
Murray you gotta go through and sort
these things into let's see what's that
well yeah they're not noted into whether
they've been green-lighted or not okay I
can do that um it's just noting that in
in the list I mean we've got a whole
list here let's um let's note whether
they've been green-lighted okay yeah and
and and also note who is working on the
middle yeah okay because we've also got
here yeah what when are we going to talk
about it around
let's go called around or is it called
about we can't change it if you want but
well I lost a lot of time thinking about
around so what is the state of it
it's
well it is the lane I haven't worked on
yet for some time but yeah it's time for
12 and so let's let's meet them about it
okay I just have to to retake the bridge
okay all right who else is working on
that nobody it's just me
oh okay fine um all right
and by the way Nick when are we going to
see more of the time and date stuff so
we've been working a Roger is interested
in Jose and I have been looking with
some of the group pretty intently at the
temporal data or not temporary temporal
logic and how that interface is with the
language
I don't know Jose we probably still need
a little bit of fleshing out before we
have it yes this is a large area and we
have some basic design of the operators
who need like until next etc but but we
need to work on applications to make
sure that we understand let's mean it
here and something good is that we have
found that the leading developers are
also working on that so they may have
support for the computational part of it
which rice that would be nice
so we can prove theorems about temporal
situations exactly but be cool mm-hm
um okay and okay just looking down our
list here whatever happened to faded
form the effort to have the thing that
we do often in blog posts where we will
have a display of some output and it
fades out after some at some point I
remember I send this to front-end and
they they discuss this in user
assistance if I remember correctly I am
not sure what did you guys decide sure
they were ejected at that but I mean I I
think that it is not something that's
worth doing look it's something we
clearly have code for I mean maybe it's
something for the function repository
for right now
Acey maybe that's the right place for it
let's get the code we have right now
that already exists that does things
like producing outputs that show a
little tear marks at the bottom and so
on
and let's get at that ready for the
function repository but you should note
that in this master list here okay um I
have a note here the parent directory
with multiple level parent directory has
been implemented is that correct yes
okay what was this graph sources graph
syncs that's two
happen no I don't see that happen III
send that to charge that is the last
update I had okay well we still we need
to find out from Charles what the story
is yes um do you have any idea I know
it's wrong group of people here but
array plot 3d that's a shoddy story I
don't know what the what the current
status of that is though okay I can I
will check please um okay
I'm just looking down my my list here
this whole
yeah um there's an effort yeah there's a
bunch of things that I don't think are
relevant to this meeting the the
business with hashing for key derivation
functions like H Mac that is being done
right or already got done any idea I
know nothing about that okay um okay
well I think um Sushma we better go
through this long list at some point and
try and clean up where each of these
things are supposed to go
yes happen textile or a plot that's a
zero xandred's list okay yes whatever
happened to the Combinator evaluate
craziness that was something that Todd
had worked on with
somebody in our mentorship program and I
know that produced code
I suspect nowadays that should go to the
function' repository maybe you can find
that okay I can do that interested in
looking at that code okay I mean I think
it was fairly extensive code I think the
main issue is the the naming of
Combinator's and the fact that things
that would otherwise be KMS of chaos or
whatever become Combinator K etc etc etc
there was a print form that looked
fairly nice
I mean Combinator's have been obscure
for a hundred and one hundred about a
hundred years gosh it's it's coming up
for the hundredth anniversary of
combinators we should celebrate that um
should remember that actually yeah we
have to get further than we have all the
information that I I think I should just
push it forward and I will send it to
you as a look at it okay I remember
working on an example in the current age
on grenadiers right what's the story
with these functions this geometric
sequence arithmetic sequence da we are
we doing these are we not doing these do
we think they're unnecessary so last
time you asked me to check with Roger if
there something you want to do and he
wasn't worried about it you said it is
too simple that is a ridiculous response
gosh okay it's like like we have
polygons of arbitrary numbers of
vertices but we don't have triangles I
don't think that's a good response if
necessary why don't you um what aspect
okay well why don't we talk about that
and some other related things and get
Roger in a meeting in one of these ILD
meetings to talk about this okay what
you saying was it is very trivial with
table yes of course it is but it's still
a useful way to package and I would
think there are things that can be done
yeah I think it's a useful way to
well okay let's let's get Roger in one
of these meetings to talk about this
whatever happens a complex plot another
thing that is also trivial to do in
quotes that was in dreads to-do list I
think it is tall for now but I yeah I
wouldn't ever checked with him before I
say anything else it was an intern
project and it's brought its not
complete the last time I checked okay um
so what do these say update pending that
this is from a long time ago yes that is
I when I and there is looking at all the
talking to people about their updates
and we didn't really collect updates for
those but I I think we I want I have to
go back through this entire list and
find out updates okay okay
I think there's a lot of stuff here that
may have gotten dropped
whatever happened to text trim that
seemed like a useful function
well it's a love affair we're going
we're diving into this list without
without warning and I'd been I'm off
agenda here so I suppose we should
pursue should wrap it up for now here um
I think the main message here gosh
there's a lot of stuff here where it's
like design is complete like rule space
data and so on
keep press pain you know anything about
these
um okay great well thanks to everybody
on the oh yeah someone on the Pharaoh
and our live stream is asking on the
subject of complex plot how but a
complex map a function similar to what
wolf malphur does you actually I'd be
interested to hear what Hosea and others
would say about that that's a conformal
mapping story what is that what is the
story with that it's a bit like like map
projections so starting with with greet
in some space projecting it and getting
the greet what we do with the geo grid
lines things of that that's pretty great
what this did how do I get one of these
complex maps I don't know how to do it
I'd see there's the Sun oh there we go
yeah it's not beautiful so okay just to
take a minute here um we are a little
over time but but um take a minute here
just talk about what that's very ugly a
bitmap I guess that's what we get for
not doing the official downloaded here
but in any case how would we represent
that what is that well it's a function
what you wrote is a function of a
complex variable or in general if we
want to do there are two to our two days
will be m and general function from two
coordinates to two coordinates which is
what what do we do with projections but
so explain that to me I mean so if I say
gee oh I mean if I'm going saying
Geographics do do graphics
background:none and geo grid lines
automatic and then choose a projection
geo grid lines to automatic the healin
projection
yeah so that that grid there is that
mapping I understand
looks like an airfoil right so yeah yeah
so there are more properties that you
can obtain from them and some of the
projections are conformal so if you do
do projection data string conformal you
get a list of our conformal projections
some projections that that preserves
angles by the way why didn't that
autocomplete that seems to armed action
bug yes because this is a class not our
projection so it still also it should
still that's a plugin autocompletion
system okay so I mean these are very
specific you know each one of these
could be defined by a function right how
would I give a function here instead of
giving like Albers I mean Albers must be
at some level of function okay yes yes
internally they all go to functions as
we compile etc so we don't have way
exposed to allow the users to specify
their own functions but we could the
main obstacle is this issue of do we ask
them to write degrees or radians latter
on or long light is sort of thing yeah I
understand yeah but I mean in this case
here mapping r2 to r2 mm-hmm
what you're saying there okay so what
what one could imagine I'm a little
confused here because I mean isn't it
image what is the image transformation
right is something very much like that
isn't that mapping r2 to r2 this is also
a benefit to do it
what is it doing exactly it's taking for
a given image right if I have an image
of the earth just to be clear and what
is like like so let's say I say
Geographics in this video image because
it wants an image okay fair enough okay
so that so if I do that then I'll get
some funky image of the earth okay okay
so what for example if I want to do a
Mercator projection know if I what do
you know a projection do you know one of
the projections if I if I just have the
identity here that will show me whatever
the war geo images right which is some
kind of equal rectangular projection or
something the world by default your
image chooses my Mercator so this is
negative Egyptian okay has an awful lot
of Antarctica there yes the poles are
again expanded by the Mercator
projection that's why exactly yes we are
cutting at 85 degrees like everybody
does to make this a map square okay all
right so so what will be an example of a
projection that is in a sensible
projection here that I could use well
the formulas I don't know try I don't
even remember the notation
isn't what isn't Mercator some kind of
arc hyperbolic cosecant or something yes
the logarithm I mean the longitude is
preserved the latitude is expanded there
are formulas but one of them if I were
to do this here what does this take as
pixel position P corresponds to F of P
so for example if I were to just say
square root here then it would do that
it's a cool example by the way mmm
you should put that into the image
transformation examples can somebody
switch where could you could you do that
yes
um okay so so but the basic point here
is this is doing a transformation if we
were to put gridlines on here this is
doing the kind of transformation we're
talking about right
um so were we to take a grid I don't
know how to make a grid actually that's
another thing that we don't have it's
something that makes an image that is a
grid it's kind of a funky thing that's
it could you suggest that Sushma to
shadi
um but no case I mean we can clearly
synthesize one but the question is other
than for visualization for example you
know this complex map visualization
what would we do here are we going to
see that that's the thing that's kind of
confusing to me um
yeah I mean so the way it would look it
might be some complex map plot and what
it is is it's like a parametric function
what the heck is it I mean one thing
it's very weird here is this is a map
this is a plot of a space it's a
representation of a space with nothing
in it
mm-hmm well I would say we could use
complex notation and we have a complex
function there and then comma C from a
complex number to another complex number
and they represent yeah yeah I
understand it's got to be the pure grid
lines right I mean because the other
thing you would do is have as you say
here a picture of the world so to speak
which is then transformed in a
projection right but this thing here is
the pure projection part of it yeah all
right
Sushma let's add this too I mean when we
talk about complex plot we should also
talk about this okay um okay we should
wrap it up thank you everyone and
everyone on the livestream missed
someone is pointing out that if one
could do it for the complex map case it
would be nice to see the transformation
from a 2 by 2 matrix for example on yeah
I mean look the basic class of things
that we don't really have are a
representation of the transformation our
space we are used to transforming things
that have content like an image for
example not a representation purely of
the transformation of a space we have
the transformation but it's restricted
to this class of linear fractional
functions no I understand that but the
point is that that what we don't have
from a graphics point of view is a
representation of what happened to an
empty space otherwise known as what
happened to the grid lines for example
right I mean you know all of our
plotting functions plot something I say
one example that doesn't okay so if I
take graphics yeah what happens if I say
graphics and then I say I'm plotting
nothing and I'm saying let's say plot
range like 0 to 10 range I don't think
if I can just say 10 and then I say
gridlines Harrow automatic okay that's
low 50 or something thing here and now
let's curious the grid line that we
didn't end up with more grid lines but
now what happens if we say a scaling
function does that do anything does that
make any sense no graphics doesn't take
scaling functions yeah well this is we
would end up with the same problem of
Geographics that has to distinguish grid
lines from geo grid lines which are the
projected and unprojected so I can
imagine that create lines are always in
the projected space so they are going to
be also equispaced um so you can also
have
fix both grid lines and geoglyphs
immediately
yeah I understand for the projected and
um projected cases exactly
yeah well deal as it's called the
graticule livestream was mentioning
something about a linear algebra intern
position about working on linear
transformations well maybe somebody's
already on top of this and we don't know
it um
fair enough okay let's wrap up this
meeting thanks everybody talk to you
soon